皆さんアニメ好きですかもう日本の文化が大きな一つとして兄うってものがあるんです
けども言わせていただきましょうアニメ
最高です僕が他のアニメに目覚めたのが小学56年のぐらいの時なんですけどもその時
は何かアニメばっかり見てるとなんか起毛が撫でる時代だったんですよアニメオタクと
か長さの可愛い模様 a 的なアニメを見ていると僕らすって一致見られてるグソの
イジメだねをしなかったですけど言ったら絶対いじめられた空気があったら絶対誰にも
言わなかったんですけど
をが沿いオタクっぽい友達と2人でコストで小学校の高学年のころから見てて今に至る
んですけどもまぁ行きエッセイ時代になりましたよねには別にダブライブ好きとか言っ
ても何にも言われませんからねほんといい時代になったと思いますそんな小学校の時
からアニメだけだった僕が果たして中前に僕がいままで生まれてきた中で取れアニメを
見てきたのかなっていうのはちょっと調べてみようと思いま
まずな父母結構言うんですよなアニメ好きですとかなんかゲーム好きでしたから
どっちかてたインド後は外で食べないとかよく言ってるんですけども
はぁ
この髪型でそれを言っていいのかなと僕疑問に思いまして波てメスチャラいとかな
アウトドア系っぽいとか何か言われるんですけども
今回のこれから見せる今まで僕が人生で見たアニメの数を見るとあぁ端お前は本物だっ
たなと
本当にアニメをがよく見るならっていうのを皆さんにお伝えできればいいなと思って
おります
強い子
入ってゆ付属喋っていきましょうねなんか wikipedia さんです日本の
テレビアニメ作品縁あっていうのがあって多分これ見れば日本なんで全部載ってると
思うんですよねそこから僕が今まで生まれてきただから見てきたアニメがどれくらい
あるのかなっていうのをちょっとカウンターで図っていきながら何を見たのかなって
いうのを計算していこうと思いますわかんない戻れ回見るのが大田区なのかどれくらい
見てるとすごいと言われる
のはわかったんですけどとりあえずちょっと見てみますね
全然年は病のアイシールド21浴びましたね
ic 21ジャンプでやってたんでこれアニメちょっと見てましたね青の祓魔師見て
ました
ブーバーさんが奥に歌ったりしてるんですごい素敵ですよアオハライド編みましたね
少女なんてたまに見るとキュンとするんですよねに入ってたこれ赤毛の見てましたね
アニマックスで見てましたっけなぁアカメが斬る3
てましたこれすごい結構グロいんですよね色々とあのすみますアクセルワールド見て
ましたこれならさうざーどんないのはあのなんか未来の話みたいな子時どうなるんです
けどこのとても良かったですねあとの花を見たことを言いますどっち勝つの真ん中に
入ったカーブを覚えられるような
まあ結構な変態チックな話なんですよあった心地めっちゃ見てましたオープニング好き
ですあの花ハイアーの花火ましたあの
北
感動したけどあんまり総裁骨董絆カップで何か先が見えちゃってもういいかいもう良い
はもう見えてました
今までこんなに知らないにもあるんだ穴にブレイディアント番組でわかりますこれで
好々亭な男の子かな遊園地のば再構築というか今日に陥った唯一を振ってるっていう
感動の話なんですけども結構なんかを魔王てがファンタジックな感じも混ぜてです
こういう楽しくプレイさせが今日はねといったところでしょうかアラド戦記みましたね
あんまり僕は好きじゃなかった
アレス sos 見てました nhk でやってたんですけどもオープニングすごい
可愛い数です今日
をもうまた誰か
音アグセラー見せましたにアルスラーン戦記なんか僕あんまり戦う系そんな見ないです
よねアレクサンダーセンチ見てましたねあなたのキスを数えましょうってゆうあい
いちご100%見てましたね僕は東條さん推しです1周がフレンズ見てましたね1週間
続くですね記憶がですね
ぜひ見てくださいとっても良いです相宮さん見てたなぁ皆さん見てました
映画まず見に行ったほうがいいよ異能バトルは日常系のなかで見たことあります学園
ものなんですけどもこうなんかよくある伊能系っぽい感じだったんですよなんかたまに
ね
お前お金ないでしょみたいな音なんかを掘るシーンがあってそこがすごい印象的でした
by れてバーガーで見たことあります来なくても良かったです
泣きました映画を楽しみですうみねこの中に見たことあります全部バトラーだけならば
虎って主人公
しながらでれながら
みてくださいエルフェンリート見たことありますこれで僕が見てきたアニメの中で一番
黒かったですね2番目かな
それでもいろいろ手足とかも切るんだよちょっとグロいの苦手な方は見ない方がいいと
思います
御山字どれには博雅せながら見てますだねなんか
おっと今度番観ちゃダメなのかなと思ってあのこっそり弟と見てました
オレオの方にみました主人公神戸たきゃってねえっす
すごいなんか筋肉よあって珍しいタイプの主人公だなと思いました
でも持ってるんですやっぱオレンジみたいな清水なんだったと思うんですけどなんか
10年後か手紙が来るその手紙を見てなんか未来を公開てるみたいなめっちゃ多かった
ですっていう少女漫画あたりが多いんだよなはい終わりのセラフ3な事あります
めっちゃ好きですあの人間が絶滅した後の話なんですけども9きっ
違うなか世界を支配しちゃってその中でも生き残った人間だけで高級穴なんてまで戦っ
ていく話なんですけども
広いにあたるのほかね種のってことそういう不思議な感じでとても好きですあ
カウボーイは文ましたこれめっちゃかっこいいか+かすみ見てた nhk でしょ
そうそうかずに見たことありますふしぎな島のフローネアニマックスで見てました超
懐かしい
がっこうぐらしれていましたこれ
でも年かその8ギャップがすごくアットエスぜひ見て下さいおすすめします学校の怪談
見たことありますかヒロインともう一人のあの男の子がいるんですけどその子の名前が
はじめですかてきょーヒットバネ棒見てましたの僕もですね
ませんになりたいと思いました付割烹の解決を見てましたああずっとこれあの多分語っ
てるとほんとに強いがないと思うんですよね端折っていきますけど本当なんでいつはに
なってみたことあるアニメしかカウントしませんのでご了承くださいませ
神様家族みた喰霊零みました黒かったガンバの冒険みましたね
イタチが強かった規定集みましたねアニメ版描画+好きでした
基底材左官字幕てみましたガンダム木見てないんですよねなぜか起爆でをレンジャーの
見てますちょっとエロくてドキドキしながら見てました
キミキスみました j 女型の結構有名なんですけど猫アニメバー好きですよ3組
くらいのカップルが校同時進行で話が進んでいくという君に届けみました
金のいる町みましたあの結構僕の好きなアニメランキング上位に入るよ
です下馬生んだ日和ワンツースにみましたオープニングが特徴的ですたという意味が
わかりませんギルティークラウンみましたあの音楽が美しい
傷が切れましたモンスト家ラボ的になってみました均熱少年みました
銀魂みました3世代の多すぎてやばいんだよクラッシュギアみました
クラッシュギア l を見ましたいやー黒子のバスケ度も観てないんだよ
思って見てないかも知ればけいおん見ましたけいおんに日々ました
要はね圧にゃんっていっこ下の学年の子はいるんですけども上が卒業する時の音音楽が
もう天使にふれてをとても良いですてみてください決壊しました結界先生見えました
面白いですよちょっと暴力的ですけどケロロ軍曹見てました
攻殻機動隊 stand alone complex みました交響詩篇
エウレカセブン3
明日栄養を述べました口舌上の姓にみましたゴールデン帯増えました
こうこさんマジ好きです結構見てるとねうんかねないようとアギレの名前一致という
ことがたまにあるんだよな
特に最近な夢は名前が長いんでなかなか覚えられないですよね
こっちから見てましたねこどものじかん見てましたまた小学生の女子が先生にこうやっ
ていろいろ恋路書をするって言って先生も
なんかこう時とかなんともいえないです僕は好きでしたこの遊びました
斉木楠雄のサイ難でいました最終兵器彼女みました目
チャスティですないってこういうしたくなりますこれ見るとてがめっちゃオススメで
好きな人がいるとかいう人はぜひ観てほしいですね
サイボーグクロちゃんみました最後崩れないみました災害彼女の育てかた今見てます1
をカウントしますさとえさん
ホワイトハウとシーン日のメッツ見てたみたいなません残響のテロルみました
テロリストの話なんですけど結構面白いです後は悲しい感じ
3丁目のタマうちのタマ知りませんが見てましたアニマックスで年的な三つ編み
引っ張ってっていうかとっても良いです4月は君の長女ましたバッチ泣きました
地獄少女は1期と2期だけ見ましたよみさ
少年だという概念が存在しない退屈な世界みましたこれはガチで面白かったですが意味
わかんなかったです社外金がにみました
削減の佐川一致とにキトサン切りました進撃の巨人見てねー
漫画だったあ新世紀エヴァンゲリを見ました鈴鹿みました
涼宮ハルヒの憂鬱みましたこれが僕のアニメの原点です小6の時から激しいにはまって
いく
用意してそっからアニメが好きになっちゃいましたねスプーンおばさん見てました
スプーンの大きなローバーさんの話で沿いが見てましたねゾイドスラッシュゼロ見てた
操船学園龍馬みましたあと1機だけ想像あと前は1期2期3期でみました
それいけアンパンマンも見てましたね多分だがしかしてみました面白かった盾の勇者の
成り上がり最後に行ってましたに見てましためっちゃの方です
異世界モノアニメて結構多いねってもなんか合気だりのパターンで主人公が強い花が
咲き多いんですけどこれに行かず主人公が最悪のスタートだったので中今までと違う点
ができても良かったです断末みましたねニキも今見てます中華一番観てました
放送中に充てた中二病でも恋がしてみましたに決まりました
家になることができましたせ超特急ヒカリアン見てました
超子供の時という目地
のアドベンチャー見てました0 to 意味でましたテーマず見てましたフロンティア
は見てないんだが征伐見たりクロスウォーズにてました
デッドマンワンダーランド見てましたけどこれ地区打ち切りになってなんじゃないって
いうテラフォーマー山に埋めましたて誰も見てましたね
ウェーバーが多くに歌ってる気がする電脳声で見てましたねこれ nhk でやってた
気がするなあとはで魔術の禁書黒子君てました
レーガンを見てました目録2見てました電池4 s 見てました
3機がまだ見れてないですよねとよろしいとっちょもお揃いですぜひ見てください
トーキョーグールみましたルート a もみました東京までにちょっと貼ってる0み
ました
東京レイヴンズみましたね大明神の話なんですよドラえもんを見てましたね
カウントしていたがなんかみんな東部見つめてくるんだよなドラゴンボールを見てまし
た z 見てましたち
いいもんでました海は3じゃなくてそうスーパーございました実がてる子美彩子ですと
のグラボみましたこれも名作というかつ動い話ですねとラドラーもねあの個人的に
タイガーがめちゃくちゃかわいくて好きでしたね
ドローンを見てました結構最近だったね凪のあすから見てましたねこれめちゃくちゃオ
ススメです中で国せるに
んでと文にする人間に分かれてる派みてください阿南極小でパパっと見てましたね
日常見てましたねっちゃちゃ好きですもんだが逆漫画って言うセンスが済むんですよ
あの単発で見れるので市は5編みですよねぜひ入れてください
結構僕の笑労組的なものを肯定したある女の一つですねニがニャンだーニャンダー
かめん見てましたこれ朝見えましたに毎朝みんながランドローン
てましたねの下なら見てましたねー荻沼を持して映画化されてて
主人公の妹がいるんですけどめちゃくちゃゲームが強いって無双2の話です這いよる
ニャル子さん2期までで思いますか鋼の錬金術師まあ確かに目で見てましたねまっくて
10度ベイブレード見せました2000人は見てて gm 電車も見てましたバッキー
物語は化け物中でだけ見たん
ですよね熱く意味でちょっとがいちご100%書いてらっしゃるんでしょこれアニメ見
てました初年後いかにマンな
見てました大変の訪独は1期と2期見てな気がします感じ dears に出まして
サッカーの話なんてよねこれ主人公ちょっとなんか
オレンジ色の髪の毛だったり覚えがある日が白いで見えましたこれ見るとですねビッグ
スクーター人タイプなんだとあと何かすごい
めちゃくちゃお金持ってたらどう
仕様って妄想が膨らむで是非オススメひぐらしのなく頃にはもう女房みました海もい
ました
日々ユーフォニアムみました映画も見に行きましたしこれは別ですいそうだけど本気で
立たず競っていた方にぜひ見てほしいなって思います特製そうだったら全然やってない
んですけど部活に一生懸命取り組む姿勢とか
全国のコンクールに向けて頑張りするかというか寝糞人間関係とか
女子なんで女神7であの服だ
何民間型とかあるんですけどそんなことが邪魔だし書かれてるってこと薄めですてみて
ください映画版もそして産地も決定おめでとうございますキモズまでチャーマー it
日記見てました
可愛いですよね強化最近見てますふしぎ遊戯でました
なんか普通の高校生の女子がよねっていうのもなんか中国の時代に飛ばされてそこには
政略言葉なんか作と l のいるんですけどそのイケメン
いい中を支配下になって物語くすんでるんですよたまにエロいのがあって僕は好きでし
た
ブラックブレットめっちゃ好きでしたねロリな女の子 l んです良い音シーエタって
いう女の子と一緒に来なく敵を倒すんですけどもなくさにしたら子どもとの関係性が
とっ
i ですそりゃあプリキュアは初代だけ打つようにてましたねプリズ助ける見てまし
たらもうド変態アニメなんですけどめちゃくちゃストレートでをもその中で変態王子と
笑わない猫見てました
僕だけがいない街で見てましたこれめっちゃ好きですひょっとした好きなアニメ
ランキングにぐらいだと思いますこれ僕のヒールはかでレイヤーは今途中まで見てます
1丁担当します
僕らのみました&ちょっとネタバレ弾ジェリー
あんまり張った方ってものが衝撃的ですごいですポケット大スター3 the 結構見
てたんですけども初代と近隣番号を見てパターンスティネーションから忙しくなって見
なくなったんですけど xi & z だけは全部見ましたね
サトシ立候補がめっちゃ発行額です毒が忘れたけどたしか最初にが手前
ぐらいで不安なときはマジでないの地球滅亡こういうことしようとしてマジでヤバイ
ことが起きるんですよそれを貯めたりにまさかのカロス地方の準備いたが全員出てきて
一線にする止めようとするときに流れる主題歌の女がオープニングのマジでよかった
です後作画を過去作最高って言われてるんでぜひとも x はよ絶対見てほしいです
このば見てました5分後方を見てました
bash land
を見てましためっちゃ懐かしい方覚えてね魔法科高校の劣等生見てましたね魔法陣
グルグル見てましたね迷いが見てましたねだから自殺志願者がまとまってバスで何か
自殺旅行みたいに行く話なんですけどでなんか普通地図には載ってないミランに行くん
ですけどもねそので流れがすごいよかったです迷い猫オーバーラン見てました
雷て見せました o
変わり身なさを変えてみましたただいまもみました未来に行ってみましたこれを個人的
にすごい好きでしたね重機てるく主人公の生きていくに対するが左右のちゃんの猛
アタックがもう
犬なんですけど素敵ですメイドやりせみましたこれも苦労があったわけですけど何が
可愛い分な緩和されてるんですけどもその主義な空気感が良かったですやはり俺の青春
ラブコメはまちがっている族もみました
ニッキー
いやちょっと頑張り響かなかったんですけど行っキーかメッチャくちゃん多かったそう
だままライナーが見てた思い出があるな
露木を水でもさぁづ全部見ましたアークファイブを見てましたねゆうゆう発掘
ちょっとずうまで見てましたね超見る韓国しましょうヨスガノソラ見てました
あの今まで見てきたジムで一番エロかったです焼きした見てましたね幅日の次にハマっ
たアニメです[ __ ]っても可愛かったですなぐらいでもう半身ましたこれはブルーに
剣心見てました
でリセラブル少女コゼット見てましたらめっちゃねー可愛いですよ
rozen maiden も1機だけ見てましたねロックマンエグゼ3てます
アクセスまで見てたお得に今や難しいも見てましたねはいここからアルファベット入り
ますねえあーみました
これも泣けますねもう key 作品ですよエンジェルビーツみましたこれもだけます
あなたを黒いけどめっちゃ面白かった個人的にはおすすめですシャーロットみました
これも良かったですねけっこい
能力系なんですけど染みやすいと思います裏な飛びましたナンバーワンだ
感動します家族の大切さを教わりますねパターンがぜひ見てください絶対見てほしい
ですゲート自衛隊彼とついてなんだかなど戦いでみました
自衛隊でですね魔法の世界に話したんですけどこれを面白いですよパウダー判断に見て
ました
可能見たはこれもキーのやつでしょ見合わせみましたサイコパスみましたに決まりまし
ためっちゃ好きでつねもりあかね監視官が大好きです
理大附見ま
3位0もみましたもうすぎる気がしますねクールデイズで食べました
今なく5なアニメは最高です語彙力が無くてすみませんスラムダンクを見ました感じ目
シュタインズゲートみましたね君ましたトラブルみましたねー
アニメのほうがあんまり広くなかったんですよ
はいこんなもんですかねどんなんでなんか誰[ __ ]とかあなたの滞在とか色々なかって
気がするんですけど花咲くいろは途方もなくなかったほかあった
動いなんかめっちゃ逃してる気がしますっていう追加でも覚えているのは花咲くいろは
打ついいかあなた myself yourself っていうのも見てました
てくださいてみましたずるーテイアスっていうアニメを見たんですよ
こうみたアニメでのっけないのが多い気がするんですけども
凪のあすからまた最近これのさんもう一個あったさあ色つで世界のあすからとかさ
ダーリン坂ランティスがメッツ抜けてる気がするんですけどいやーなんかそれで
wikipedia 度全部がアニメ化に乗ってない可能性があります
日本のテレビアニメ作品一覧に載ってないのは多々あるんですけど200作品は子
れてると思うね全然まだめっちゃる気がすんだよなんだかまぁネックですを見てるんで
なかなかちゃんとした成長は出てないんですけど多分200作品は溶融で見てるくらい
だと思います入ってるけどちょっと今見たアニメが他にオススメのアニメがあったら
ぜひ皆さん教えて下さいますね全力で見させていただきます本読むの苦手なんですけど
その分アニメにまたステータス全部にしたみたいな感じなんで
チェッコアニメ観て育っているところがあると思いますぜひ何かお勧めのアニメがあっ
たら教えてください
じゃ
[音楽]
me
あっはっ